Kelly Dodd hi Brian I am back for your
fourth season I know can you believe it
how are you feeling about season 14 I
would say it's a show that's something
quite honest you don't know what you've
done to me seem safe to say that the big
drama within the group focuses on you
yes okay it's all about Kelly God Kelly
can we talk we're gonna see you and
Vicki come face-to-face right I would
imagine the first time since the reunion
mm-hmm how does that go she chases me
around
Tamra's house she just knows how to poke
the bear
so I really don't want to give her the
time of day so I'm kind of getting mad
at her because I just want her to leave
me alone and she just kind of like
chases me around
Tammy was literally in a circle why do
you think she is so invested in talking
things out with you well it thinks that
she wants to be a part of the group I
think that you know if you see like the
first probably the couple of episodes
she's kind of like an outcast
nobody really kind of wants to deal with
her and if she makes things right with
me everybody will be more apt to keep
get her and back into the group we see
she calls you a bully in the trailer yes
that had to hurt well no it didn't hurt
at all because that's that's all she got
I mean that's all she has like oh I'm a
bully like what about all the other
stuff that she does not sound well big
act knows right
I don't do cocaine sorry I don't it
didn't hurt me because she was the bully
see whole entire season she's poking me
poking me poking me poked me so it's
funny to see that she calls me the bully
you know I used to like hate her and
like like have this like spies like just
like I just could not I despised her and
you know I went through therapy with dr.
Dow dr. Michael Dow and you know it you
know he'd told me not to wrestle with
pigs so to speak you know and don't do
that and you know he really taught me
you shouldn't hold on anger you should
you know be happy for everyone and I'm
really trying to work hard you know not
holding on to that negativity I would
rather not have her in my life ever
again I just don't want that negativity
and I know how she can turn so I would
prefer not to over like really have a
friendship or talk to her ever again
talk to me more about this therapy what
inspired you to get into therapy and
what have you learned about yourself
through that process well I got into
therapy because I do have a temper
I don't want to react I need to know the
tools on how to not just blow off the
handle and it was you know trying to get
over you know these women coming after
me and spreading lies and rumors and you
know I really needed to know how to find
solace and myself and tools on how to
not blow up on them and beat the crap
out of them basically yeah that's not
gonna get me anywhere no yeah
so on the outs with Vicki how are you
with the other two-thirds of the tres
amigas I was really tight with Tamra
really tight with Shannon and then they
have this like tres amigas things so
they form this kind of like this game
mentality it's so it's like my season
one again it's like Groundhog's Day did
you feel like the new girl again I felt
like the new girl again this season it's
exactly the same thing for me I feel
like yeah she's completely ruined my
reputation
I have nothing to say to you okay I'm
really upset that Tamra and Shannon
haven't picked a lane they all hated her
for forever why are you choosing Vicki
over myself it doesn't make sense to me
you know the other franchises they have
a panting gate or they concentrate on
the dog no no no this is like a show I
think that it's it's it's gonna be
probably the best season out of all 14
seasons I feel like I'm on Game of
Thrones yourself
I have not revealed all what I know I
feel like you're behind this is there
anything you're dreading having to watch
that
yeah I'm dreading to watch all of it
back you know it's gonna be hard for me
it's going to be an entertaining one to
say the least